[Music]
welcome back to cbs mornings
best-selling author david mcgee usually
writes about business leaders and sports
figures but his latest book dear william
a father's memoir of addiction recovery
love and loss turns the focus inwards to
his own life struggles he says it was a
way to understand his son's death from a
drug overdose jim maxwell shows us how
mcgee's book is more than just a story
of sorrow it's also about resilience and
hope
they had this idea to build this
letterman's walk nothing makes david
mcgee prouder than his son's name on the
letter winners walk at the university of
mississippi there's something about
having that
name your son's name for that work he
did engraved you know
right there
and nothing makes him sadder as well she
had a tear
every time i come
william mcgee lettered in track at ole
miss while attending the honors college
he was his dad says
a golden kid and that's the whole point
isn't it that is the whole point i mean
it'll take anybody down in 2013 less
than a year after graduation william
died from a drug overdose
to get on the phone you know to
your child's mother
my wife
and say
he's gone
hardest words
you'll ever say
david mcgee's journey to understand what
happened to his son
is now a brutally honest memoir dear
william i had to go look at what
happened
in our family how did this
what looked like a picture-perfect
american family chasing that dream how
did that dream get completely shattered
you and william were learning to ski
mcgee tells a story of intergenerational
trauma how his parents lies about his
adoption
how his struggle with alcohol how his
infidelity all led to suffering for his
wife and three kids
a story he thinks will resonate
in many homes and i think that's why i
went that deep
in revealing
what was a very honest story
about just an average american family i
mean we're nobody
we're just everybody his wife kent and
his son hudson who had his own
near-fatal overdose were both on board
with this highly public airing of their
family trauma i just think that with
everything that happened to me and to
william something good has to come from
that brutal total honesty is the best
medicine
i've been told and you know keeping
secrets make you sick but
turning toward your painful story and
owning it
is essential or else it owns you he kept
daily going back to substances to alter
his feeling mcgee has now dug in
speaking to any students who will listen
and delivering a wake-up call to parents
about their kids loss of hope do you
feel kids today are nose to nose with
despair in a way that maybe their
parents generation wasn't
absolutely something has changed
generationally i consistently hear from
them
i'm not sure if i can get a job as good
as my dad had i'm not sure i could buy
the house we have i'm not sure i'll be
able to buy a car then add in fallout
from the pandemic a study on its effect
by duke university psychologist kenneth
dodge shows the greatest spike in
substance use was seen in adults 19 to
22
and the children of parents with
substance issues run an even higher risk
for substance abuse a young adult looks
to her or his
parents about what their hopes were
and if that person sees difficulty that
makes it harder to feel hope a fact that
still cripples david mcgee our children
were falling apart before our eyes but i
was so lost in our own my struggle that
i couldn't see it so to help a kid who's
in crisis
before you look just at the kid
spend some time at the mirror and you
will not always like what you see hello
his family has started the william mcgee
center to address substance abuse at ole
miss
and then share what they learn with
other schools we have to get better at
this as a country
david mcgee's contribution is the raw
story of his family's heartbreak and
healing and he's determined to tell it
to give others hope
but you can
wrestle
meaning even from
the deepest darkest pain the darkest
moment
can
you know often be a real energy source
for
doing good and doing well and living
well
what a brave thing john talk about
cutting yourself open and exposing
yourself warts and all that's very
powerful yeah you know he said look if
you're going to do this
you got to go wide open you got to go to
the bone or else it's not going to be
helpful to other families that are
reading the story and he wants to put
that pain into service of broadening out
to address the generation a generation
of 20-somethings teens that grew up on
active shooter drills grew up on climate
crisis grew up on a political system
that seems incapable of addressing their
needs
if
if substance abuse is in an attempt to
medicate that pain understand this
generation's pain yeah it's different
it is different it is different i i do
think parents should hold themselves
accountable and ask themselves what they
did to contribute to a situation but
david seems to put a lot of blame on
himself looking in the mirror i mean
he's processing not just the death of
his son but the near death of hudson who
we just saw from an overdose so i think
his look inward is
he's carrying a weight that's a lot
heavier than even other people who've
dealt with stuff like that and i think
when people deal with tragedy the
easiest thing maybe the first thing you
want to do is ask why you look up to the
heavens and you say why but you rarely
look in the mirror and ask why and
that's what i don't think that's the
whole point but i don't know there's any
rational explanation for this sort of
stuff i mean my dad was a hard drug user
for most of his life i'm not there
i think you're raising an important
important point tony there is a gener
genetic component to some of this stuff
but it's not just that there's a whole
uh
another dimension of assessing pain
right
i wonder what's a difficult decision for
the family because listen it's extremely
personal you're talking about family and
his marital infidelity which is very
difficult i would imagine from his
wife's point of view going through what
they were going through with their
children i wonder was it hard for them
to say we're going to expose everybody i
love when he said we're nobody yet we're
just everybody everybody that is unsung
hero of the whole thing
kent mcgee that the wife was after
spending the day with the family there
is such strength and grace there it was
a privilege to be in their presence yeah
was that a little grandchild running
yeah they lived thinking right in the
backyard continuous houses so nice
building they're absolutely our
rebuilding it's really nice that was a
very powerful story thank you jim
axelrod